aujourd'hui pour cette nouvelle vidéo de
la série dans son corps on reçoit une
invitée très spéciale puisqu'il s'agit
de florence porcel mars florence et
animatrice télé et radio autrice
comédienne et youtube deux spécialistes
de l'espace en général et de mars en
particulier
salut florence salies julien alors
quelle est ta particularité à toi alors
ma particularité à moi c'est qu'on m'a
ouvert la tête en deux pour me retirer
une vilaine d'humeur au cerveau quand
j'avais 16 ans et tu meurs tu peux
raconter un peu de quoi il s'agit oui en
fait a été assez grosse claque a été
assez comme ça avec les pico parce
qu'elle avait elle ressemblait à un
oursin et il se trouve que l prenais mon
nerf optique pour un hamac et donc je me
suis rendu compte que j'avais ce truc là
parce que déjà j'avais un défaut de
vision dans l'oeil droit et que en plus
mon oeil droit le globe oculaire sortait
donc c'est comme ça que tu as au départ
je réalise et qu'il ya un truc
ouais différence est que
le châtel et subway c'est cette tâche
noire que j'avais dans ma vision est ton
la tumeur même si ce n'est pas vraiment
une c1
c'était un choeur d'hommes c'est ça
c'était un casernement exactement le
terme technique c'est caverne home
orbitaire droit inca bernos et une
malformation de certains vaisseaux
sanguins qui sont très localisés sa
forme une sorte de petite pelote à on
dit que ça ressemble à une mûre ou à une
framboise alors dit comme ça ça a l'air
très mignon mais en fait non pas
tellement en plus ça peut être beaucoup
plus gros bond a ouvert la tête en deux
je sais tout et c'est tout bah oui en
fait c'était bénin s'était pas il n'y
avait pas de cancer
heureusement même si on ne savait pas à
la base il fallait faire les analyses
sur le sur la tumeur en question donc
oui oui on m'a ouvert le crâne pour la
retirer il a dû honorer chirurgien a dû
sectionner le muscle de la paupière
droite donc pour accéder à la tumeur et
il a dû retirer les petites piques un
par un avant de retirer le gros des
trucs et c'est une opération qui a duré
six heures
un kader ne s'est pas cancéreux mais ça
peut provoquer des troubles
neurologiques en fonction de son
emplacement et ça peut aussi se mettre à
saigner le seul traitement c'est la
chirurgie s'est retiré le cadet reneaume
on fait ça pour éviter qu'il saigne et
pour arrêter les troubles neurologiques
qui provoque et du coup puisque ton a
fait une vidéo
encore un regard des efforts dire
bonjour bonjour à toi qui me demandent
si j'ai un petit caillou si j'ai un oeil
de verre ou à toi qui me reproche d'être
stressé comme ces charmantes tout ça
peut vous
des petites séquelles au niveau de la
paupière droite
ouais bah qui n'existe plus et qui
n'existent plus parce qu'il n'ya pas de
muscles à l'intérieur la peau a été
retiré aussi plus ou moins il ya eu en
fait j'ai eu quatre opérations de
reconstruction
donc en fait là ce qu'il ya c'est que
j'ai des fils de silicone à la place du
muscle et donc il n'y a plus vraiment de
pau voilà a été sectionné donc je suis
silicone et le muscle qui permet de
fermer les paupières s'appelle le muscle
orbiculaire voilà c'était pour que vous
sachiez que tu te souviens à l'époque ce
qui a été le plus difficile
bah oui je me souviens très bien le plus
difficile à vivre c'était que je
connaissais mais la date de ma mort en
fait parce que j'étais persuadé que
j'allais mourir le 13 janvier 2000 voilà
et non seulement j'avais la date j'avais
leur enfin c'est terrible d'avoir ce
compte à rebours est ce tic taliban fins
et c'est affreux donc ouais ça s'est
compliqué surtout quand à 16 ans tu te
dis mais pourquoi pourquoi moi pourquoi
si tôt enfin je n'ai appris début
décembre aux mille descendre entre mi
décembre et le 13 janvier il s'est passé
peu de temps et on n'a pas opéré avant
début janvier parce que enfin en étant
des 199
il avait peur du bug de l'an 2000 donne
du coup ils ont préféré attendre voilà
de passer à l'an 2000 pour pour être sûr
que tout se passe dans les conditions de
sécurité les plus optimales eh ben je
suis rentré à l'hôpital le 11 janvier et
j'ai fait des tas d'examens
et ouais je sais enfin je moi j'étais
persuadé que j'allais y passer
donc c'était vraiment très difficile à
vivre parce que tu passes par toutes les
étapes
tu passes par l'euphorie tu passes par
le désespoir tu passes par les larmes tu
passes par l'apathie tu passe partout en
fait tu
et une étude est dans une colère noire
parce que de profonde injustice
pourrais tu te souviens d'ailleurs le
bleu le moment où tu l'as où tu as
appris que t'avais ça ce que tu t es ce
que tu te dis c'est pas comme ça ça se
passe quand même pas comme ça c'est à
dire que ça se passe par étapes d'abord
tu vas chez l'ophtalmo qui te dit tu vas
passer un scanner tout de suite
honteux clac et pas tranquille parce que
dont on dit tout de suite bon qu'il est
déjà 19 heures donc voilà au scanner on
te dit tu vois la tête des médecins qui
font des drôles de têtes quand même et
tu te disent vous avez quelque chose qui
pousse derrière l'oeil on taira mais
qu'est ce que c'est et après on te dit
que le lendemain il faut aller faire une
irm à reims dont cac40 tente de chez toi
en urgence
donc voilà en fait ça se fait
progressivement tu sens qu'il ya quelque
chose qui va inquiéter
tu sens que ces voix là mais voilà c'est
pas d'un jour enfin du jour au lendemain
on te dit bon je sais d'avancé avant de
savoir
elles vont de savoir quand on est en
train de chercher à priori ce qui
prédomine c'est la peur
bah oui en fait je savoure je me
rappelle pas trop mais c'est surtout
l'inquiétude
ouais l'inquiétude de qu'est ce qui
m'arrive et qu'est ce qui se passe et
jusqu'où ça va aller
ouais et quand le neurochirurgien
t'explique que avec des avec un joli
sourire et démons très doux très gentil
que c'est une opération risquée qui
at-elle risque-t-elle risques tels
risques que bon faut pas s'inquiéter
quand même parce qu'il fait ça pas tous
les jours mais presque et que tout va
bien aller que comme je suis jeune et va
s'appliquer
mais bon tu sens que c'est quand même
quelque chose de
d'un peu lourd il avait prévu trois
heures d'opération ce qui était déjà
pour moi à l'époque quelque chose de
costaud et bon ça a duré 6 inflexible
mais voilà ouais c'est pas et puis oui
je sais pas pourquoi je me suis mis dans
la tête que j'allais mourir mais parce
qu'il y avait un risque
et moi je me suis focalisé là dessus
donc j'espère vraiment l'inquiétude
après la peur de la peur de mourir et
j'imagine à un moment ou un autre je
disais
sentiment d'injustice tu comprends pas
forcément tu comprends pas tu comprends
pas ça tombe dessus du jour au lendemain
donc ouais 16 ans et enfin noël arrive
enfin le 1er janvier l'an 2000 la
tempête parce qu'à l'époque il y avait
il y avait la tempête en plus donc tout
ce qui se passait dans la tête de
bordels de 1,2 de chaos en fait ça se
retrouver dans la nature
enfin c'était un moment extrêmement
bizarre et étrange et
et puis bon si je m'en sortais je
pouvais m'en sortir mais avec un oeil en
moins faim donc il y avait des
possibilités
moi je me suis focalisé sur l'api pire
parce que je sais pas pourquoi passe
comme ça dans ma tête mais ouais je
pouvais devenir un légume ou
pas un légume avec un maillot - ou enfin
bon voilà il y avait un éventail de
possibilités et je savais pas déjà
persuadé que je me réveillerai pas mais
si je me réveillais comment je me
réveille parce que je me suis réveillé
c'était pas un concert salle est de
passer après en fait parce que faut il à
baudouin fo arabe et au labo ouais donc
du coup ne pouvait pas savoir avant donc
il y avait donc déjà je me suis réveillé
et ensuite fallait savoir si en plus
j'avais par un cancer peut quand même se
trouve en suisse pour voilà alors moi
j'étais dans le gaz injecté j'étais pas
c'était sûr surtout mes parents qui
s'occupaient de ça mais moi je ne me
souviens pas combien a annoncé que
j'avais pas de cancer jeu il est trop
noir donc et
la suite après des suites immédiates et
à moyen terme alors j'ai passé quinze
jours trois semaines à l'hôpital qu'un
jour pareil c'est un peu flou tu vois
c'était juste pas en état
sachant que quand je me suis réveillé
j'ai l'impression d'être passé sous 1 38
tonnes parce qu'en fait il m'avait cassé
la mâchoire
donc j'ai un morceau de crâne en moi
enfin j'avais les deux yeux au beurre
noir je pouvais pas ouvrir la bouche
après avoir peur ouais ouais la
cicatrice commence ici je sais pas si on
peut la voir mais elle commence là et
jusqu'à jusque là derrière l'oreille
jolie cicatrices truies et non pas rasé
ils ont fait ça bien pour que justement
on a des cicatrices et ouais ouais donc
quinze jours trois semaines d'hôpital et
après je suis resté chez moi je dormais
20 heures par jour jusqu'aux vacances de
février où après les vacances de février
suis retourné à l'école j'étais en
première mais je passais mes après midi
à dormir sur la table parce que
la première évidemment et ensuite alors
si on accepte en janvier 2000
l'opération et j'ai eu des opérations de
reconstruction donc 4 jusqu'en février
donc voilà tout enfin qu'est ce que je
dis oui 2005 on février 2005 sans que
cinq bonnes années de galère et j'ai
encore des séquelles mais ça va j'ai mes
deux yeux je suis vivant je n'ai pas de
cancer tout va bien je disais que au
moment où c'est arrivé le plus c'était
la peur de mourir
aujourd'hui tout va bien en machine à
ramer le plus pénible aujourd'hui c'est
qu'est ce que c'est que ce qu'il reste
au bas ce qui est pénible c'est ben
c'est pas pouvoir faire mais
naturellement l'oeil droit
je le sens au quotidien la paupière l
est pas et pas vraiment mobile qui voit
ya une tension je sens que c'est pas
c'est pas comme à gauche voici un
d'origine
donc je peux pas fermer les yeux
naturellement je peux pas vous pour
dormir il faut que je mets dedans
bradant n'aurait l'idée d'un nounours
que je travaille partout avec moi
ouais c'est très pénible en fait c'est
bon on s'en rend compte évidemment quand
on a plus quelque chose que j'ai en fait
c'est vachement utile donc c'est chiant
et puis
et puis des migraines
enfin voilà des mi-mouche dorment à léo
donc du coup je me réveille je vois flou
donc c'est vraiment ces quotidiens ces
quotidiens maintenant je m'accommode
disons pas franchement ça va mais
j'aurais préféré ne pas vivre ça
d'accord au quotidien ça se comment
est-ce que comment est ce que tu as
appris à gérer sodium ce qu'en plus tu
tournes ailleurs suite à une boule dans
lequel tu montres ton image donc été
encore plus exposé que voilà la majorité
des gens comment comment est-ce que tu
apprends au quotidien à gérer ce genre
de choses je sais pas si j'apprends en
fait moi j'ai la chance d'avoir fait la
paix avec ça ouais c'est à dire que vous
4,4 opération tu te dis bon c'est bon
j'arrête et soit je m'aime comme ça soit
je suis malheureuse donc ben moi ça va
mais c'est vrai que quand tu reçois tous
les jours un mec qui te dit hey tu
ferais mieux d'aller voir ton héros
chirurgien je crois que tu as un
problème je crois que je n'avais pas vu
enfin mais le pire c'est que ça peut
partir d'une bonne intention prévoit
donc c'est c'est juste pénible et je
n'arrive pas en fait ça me fait pas de
mal c'est juste ça me saoule
bref c'est juste ça ça me saoule mais
parce que tout comme tu dis toi que tu
as fait ouais t'as ton ta partie du
chemin tu as fait à moi je suis
complètement sereine
moi je moi j'ai envie de répondre le mec
si je te dérange regarde ailleurs enfin
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] moi en fait je
suis là je suis comme ça qu'est ce que
tu veux comme une phase fin moment voilà
c'est comme ça et puis c'est pas
autrement et puis cette facette viennent
je ne te force pas me regarder
alors du coup le secret ce coup là pour
ça c2c d'apprendre
s'en [ __ ] en fait ouais mais le truc
c'est que ce soit pas une douleur sur
laquelle on les jours viennent appuyer
après est ce que toi tu tu arrives à
identifier comment tu as réussi à te
prendre pour être aussi sereine par
rapport à ça oui c'est à dire que moi je
pense que ça vient du fait que j'ai cru
que j'allais mourir et que après tout
paraît mais vraiment mais tu me fais un
commentaire où les hommes soul est alors
mais si tu savais la joie que c'est
d'être vivante et d'être voyante à la
fin d' être devoir bien je prends je
pense non et puis quand enfin je n'étais
pas enfin je raconte ça voilà quinze
jours d'hôpital machin mais franchement
cette fois ci c'est vrai tu t'es
vraiment dur c'était vraiment dur et
puis à l'hôpital j'ai vécu des trucs
vraiment pas cool
donc du coup quand tu visa et qu'après
tu es en bonne santé
tu vois correctement enfin juste tu peux
vivre ta vie faire des choses
respirez voir le monde avec tes deux
yeux voire en couleurs parce qu'il ya
pendant six mois j'ai été borgna donc en
six mois j'ai la paupière et ecopetrol à
et donc donc j'ai commencé à perdre la
vie en trois dimensions ensuite je pense
que c'était psychologique mais j'ai
perdu un petit peu les couleurs et donc
quand way des fois juste m'arrête je
regarde le monde en trois dimensions
avec des couleurs vives et un mais
génial alors les gens qui me disent
ouais t'as un tic à l'oeil de sam stress
et touche même si cette hausse presse
que je te dise je suis désolé pour toi
quoi mais c'est ton problème
ouais ouais le secret je serai
pas deux
juste pas oubliée de tous ses biens en
fait un des douze je reviens donc ce
serait si vous avez un conseil à donner
quelqu'un qui s'apprêtent à vivre leur
d'expérience que tu as vécu assez
difficile parce qu'on vit pas tous ces
choses à la manière des rançons bagram
de la manière dont on est entouré de la
chine son cerveau de de beaucoup de
choses je dirais que de toute façon il
ya un avant et un après ça c'est sûr et
que si on a la chance de bien pouvoir le
gérer après mais c'est celle qui du
bonheur pas dire ça mais mais en tout
cas ça relativise beaucoup de choses et
ça permet de très très très bien vivre
de très bien gérer les petits soucis
qu'on peut avoir au quotidien
ok et en guise de mot de la fin je te
laisse le choix soit en mot de la fin si
tu veux aux gens en général soit un mot
de la fin aux gens qui te font de la
réflexion dans les commentaires soit les
deux à tégénaire qu'est ce que tu as je
ne sais pas ah oui je voudrais
m'adresser alors en français pardon mais
à simone hilaire qui vit la même chose
en ce moment et à qui j'envoie toutes
mes bonnes rondes et beaucoup de courage
et beaucoup de soutiens parce que je
sais par quoi elle passe par quoi tu
passes et et c'est pas facile mais je
suis sûr que tu vas très bien s'en
sortir et moi j'ai confiance nous ne
sommes pas parfaits
merci beaucoup à toi merci très bien et
puis à bientôt
à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]